welcome to this video part 13 of the
pre-war Championship match series
presenting games of the two players and
it's again turn the world champion to
have the game presented and among going
back to the 2010 World Championship
match our long-term plate veselin
topalov in Sofia so in two polyps home
country and I'm not sure he's from Sofia
it's not his home city I think but he
really played them right then the
challengers own country and yeah as we
know of course are not defended the
title at the end after to pile of
basically committed suicide in the final
game too yeah he was so eager to avoid
them rapid playoffs that he played just
far too risky and aren't just one this
with the black pieces funnily enough
with the with the last guy variation of
the Queens gambit declined just not
exactly having a reputation to win games
but this game own I won't show um mostly
because it simply features um yes we
saddled play by the Challenger in this
match and I did a good job to punish
that but still um I'm going back to game
for the beginning of the match at the
time the match situation was even a nerd
had lost the first game after to par
loved one a completely prepared game in
Game one and the groom thought he had
prepared the whole game till the end
basically and are not stumbled right
into it confusing two lines and the
second game on and one nicely in a
technical game where he initiated Noli
Queen trade and
and the fourth game we saw just like in
the second game a Catalan yeah bit of a
surprise that the Catalan was one of the
main opening some being discussed in
this match are not played deform in this
match and he also played I think c4 in
one game so on we had mostly closed
openings as to par love also was not
playing money for so on somehow it's
been a while that we saw on one year
formed in World Championship chess I
mean I'm not girlfriend obviously yeah
are not played some before in this match
but not exclusively so let's see what
happens here at Apollo took on c4 his
preferred choice Bishop g2 and Jenny
Bishop b4 check um here in this position
on move five black has many moves really
it's it's a big choice on the main moves
on probably knight c6 and NC 5 in the in
the second match game if i'm not
mistaken i forgot to look that up I
think the pile of played a six and then
c5 um however y en de smet shot in this
match game four he played this check so
he deviated himself from the early loss
in Luverne game to get this check on
white answers with bishop t2 this is the
natural response something like Knight
d2 is answered by c3 and black is
winning material and this is maybe not
100% gap but white usually doesn't do
that just this is fine and now a five
protects the bishop on before yeah white
needs to take care about this pawn so he
attacks it with Quincy to
and now I like captures on d to ya here
in this position and which has been
played before quite many times already
and in this position wide usually
recaptures with the Queen and in fact
this is what I on plate um yeah it's
quite quite strange stuff to move the
Queen first here and then capture on d
too but it has some more than one
interesting point one issue of this
movie's that dumb black can really hang
on to the pond and it's a very often
risky to try to keep the porn and effect
here black also is taking some risks but
it does considered that this is a kind
of or one form of keeping the pawn that
is at least playable for black so white
players always concentrated on greene
takes d2 and queen txt to has a very
interesting technical point and this is
if black now would try to to keep the
pawn just protecting it before it is
even attacked then white has this funny
idea attacking g7 and attacking b5 so
Queen d2 is also an technically
motivated move in the game to palo
played c6 basically preparing this move
and are not answered with a form just
putting yeah just trying to make it
harder to keep the pawn with a four
however two part of any way played b5
yeah in term this has been played a
number of times before and interestingly
enough it even featured in the World
Championship match in 2006 we're at
Apollo fair play to Chrome Nick this is
the infamous toilet cage match um well
this position had been discussed so this
is a position that certainly both teams
some
had to look them I had analyzed in the
preparation however it seems that here
on earth Alan's team has simply a good
not a new idea that the polyp has a hard
time dealing with the new moves instead
of taking and Queen g5 which immediately
gets the porn back instead of that I
don't play tonight a three and it seems
that this move from is stronger in
comparison at least that puts much more
pressure on black and if you look at the
current database of games you see that
b5 is basically our business nowadays
they all play nitey form Queen somewhere
probably to see two and then 96 for the
moment keeping this pawn and then
intending to to use this we can square
on before this seems to be a quite solid
way to play with black um and probably
it'd be better for white but nothing
spectacular but we try to the game b5
was a tried and tested move at the time
and now 93 it also doesn't seem like
black black isn't lost here or even even
in super deep trouble but this position
is is very tough to play as we will see
quite quite shortly oh yeah what should
like do now it is simply attacked this
pawn and they are well you can never
really move it this is the first problem
or at least them it's something that you
need to calculate them concretely each
time something like before night c4 of
course looks terrible it's just a very
weak position for black and this night
gets into play so you almost never can
advance the pawn if white is able to
recapture on c4 taking can be an idea
not at the moment but can be an idea
later to just liquidate the whole Queen
side
but in general it is difficult to move
the beep on at any of any stage also the
sea porn and this means that you also
have a hard time moving the second
seaborne as there's always be fine thing
so these pawns are basically frozen and
this also means that black has all
pieces behind those pawns and then they
cannot advance it's it's difficult to
make any progress while white has ways
to improve the position we will see that
white has good chances to build up a
really strong game Bishop d7 now is
played which looks like a terrible move
but it's probably the only one that you
can really play um visual basics look
some more normal but look at this and
white gets the piece back with a very
nice position at the end like suffers
from two weaknesses and white has this
fantastic bishop so clear edge from
white Bishop d7 this ugly mood was
probably forced and this is also a bit
strange at least in my book wired to
pile of what would willingly go for this
position I mean him if you play this
line with b5 and he repeated the line
that he had played in a World
Championship match before you know that
Allen should have something prepared and
to be honest if you look at this
position after night a three and Bishop
d7 I mean Ian map my point of view dude
you just stop the analysis because it
looks like crap but okay he he meant it
he decided to go for that and we'll see
that it's not that clear but I would
definitely prefer to be YTM okay 95 this
is a strong post on you five and tonight
d5 to keep this diagonal closer also
this might be a square for the night
yeah here we go white takes the center
and secures the king yeah black also
castles hard to just to suggest other
moves you can try you can try other
other setups with black black's pieces i
mean but you can hardly do without
without castling 0 ft 1 strengthening
the position and also preparing the the
general strategical breakthrough here
this is d45 white tries to open up the
default at the center to get this bishop
involved and to use the the better piece
coordination it's simply that white
already is able to connect rooks it's
got a good square for the Queen which
can also be improved swinging over to
the Kings side and black is some not
really able to set up any threats or
active play p.m. is basically doomed to
such passive moves Bishop eatum doesn't
look like great but what should like do
Mets era 982 a6 not normal move trying
to get this piece out yeah then d5 and
black is completely falling apart iam
let's say it takes just for argument's
sake what should like do now and resins
this really loses the house or for
example this move you can more than one
good news Robin this is strong taking
the look pressure here this is also a
threat so it's it's very hard to even
keep keep the position from from
crumbling down immediately black
probably needs to do something like that
and this is a cap almost lost night
eight to a 6 is not working at all but
what should you do Bishop v8 has
mentioned the move that he played can
they consider Queenie 7 trying to
connect rooks but after Queen III the
threat is renewed that is to have the
night protected after d5 ed ed 5 and
here also like has some has a hard time
to defend what should you do there are
all kinds of tricks already in the
position let's say Queen moves again you
need to reckon with technical tactical
moves this is not working yet sorry but
but this is now it's always this
combination of pressure against b5 and
the central breakthrough we're here this
also substantial pressure created it's
very m it's very interesting to see how
effective this night only three is it
just has this annoying pressure against
the Queen side it covers this Square and
once black moves any carry pawns sepan
the beep on the night we'll get into
play and it's very difficult for back to
in the long run not move any of those
pawns when this breakthrough is
engineered so in the game you played
this move Bishop e8 it's not looking
great but there are it's hard to suggest
anything else yeah instead of course g5
no one no need to hesitate here white
needs to use his superior development
and superior centralized position so
opening up with d5 is just just the
right way to go yup Queen d6 was played
taking the bishop
and the night I'm sorry taking the night
and yeah here that's already an
interesting choice I played the good
move Knight g4 there also was d take c6
that you could consider Queen takes five
and eight XP five this is quite
interesting it looks like white has
excellent compensation for the for the
piece and this is probably true
especially if black fans to to recognize
the urgency of matters here um black
sony movers just to return the peace
something like that not not too clear
how he should return the piece but he
needs to something like that for example
and this position is somewhat better for
white he just has the somewhat better
coordinated pieces look already here
good night the c5 opening up the
diagonal and the main issue is that a
five is just the week upon in comparison
to to be too so this was a good
alternative this this temporary peace
sacrifice but alas movies is good it's
simply as a good and strong move where
the night can also go here in fact often
Quincy 593 exactly that happened and
this is some nicely positioned piece it
controls d5 always some making sure that
any captures arm a nasty covered and
there's also an active piece in regards
sill to the King as we will see later
yeah night to a 6 was played and yeah
black at some point needs to do that how
is he ever going to move this night we
see that this
move basically involve some an opening
of the queenside but they're already
wasn't much choice Widener took and this
means that this configuration now we'll
do one yeah we'll resolve blood takes on
a form yet could have also taken here
but after this line this is a good move
litem has clearly the better chances
those nights are not nicely coordinated
and there's still the week a five-pound
d5 the bishop so y term has a number of
positive features here it took on air
for and the a night to conceive for so
this is basically the yeah the triumph
of this night going to to the side of
the board and now black him at the end
was forced to to to capture and allow
the night back into play yeah Bishop
takes an hour Roxy one so we have a
position where black at the moment
enjoys one extra pony on a four but
white has excellent pieces those nights
the rocks are on the open files and um
yeah it's a very harmonious some good up
for white what should the black do now
um the next move um I've found at the
time very surprising and I'm still a bit
a bit surprised that to Paula played
this because I think for a player of his
level it was pretty apparent what this
movie sir is doing I mean you put h 6 cm
and okay this Sun creates some room for
the King so that back rank maids are no
issue anymore
but still this is a weakening of the
Kings side and we will see the following
line which is very yeah very convincing
I think um of course it's already a
difficult position to defend let's say
he won't do that job let's say would be
8 like a and move her to improve
slightly then non-white has this idea 96
and queen a seven then this kind of idea
well it's a five right yeah White has an
attack but still there's not night x h h
6j and look at the game he played H 696
queen move back and now g4 and now yeah
well everybody in the uncle is seeing
that night x h6 yeah will be very
dangerous because while what are those
pieces doing besides a not defending the
king and yeah now it gets very very very
critical probably it's it's not possible
anymore to to defend this position to
part of played rock to the eighth and
yeah what what else is there you could
consider f6 try to use the Queen here
which amongst others can be answered by
e 5 which is an interesting decision
takes takes an f5 and even then white
can chat can sacrifice simply because
those nights are not playing at all they
are just dead pieces this is a fantastic
piece on d6 and white also has this rook
lift threatened and of course just the
direct threat is Queen txt 6 which means
that something like whinge is having
see I truly am not really working yeah
it's it it gets it gets very ugly
something like that is a disaster what
is basically attacking with all pieces
were those nights are outside yeah he
played rock d 8 and now I'm okay check
of course and this is why age 6 really
am I didn't really get this move because
I mean what what's so difficult to
calculate here 96 you need to return and
now it's clear that he will 2nd age 6 I
mean maybe too far off thought he was in
deep trouble anyway and he wanted to
provoke him his material sacrifice too
yeah somehow yeah getting murkier
position then then in other lines were
white maybe just has a good position but
has not sacrificed but we will see that
blacks position is already beyond saving
here white some a big threat years the
movie 5 in connection with Roxy 4g for
mate and this means that black quickly
needs to organize something along the
seventh-ranked that you need to get the
Queen over here to defend some pieces
need to defend those the nights are just
standing here on the edge on the board
and do nothing you plan f6 to make this
possible but now the next moves is very
important it's not terribly difficult to
find but it always makes the whole thing
yeah work perfectly together and I
played the good movie 5 opening up this
diagonal and more importantly getting
this idea to play or movie for 2g for it
just opens up the fourth-ranked and also
cuts the ball into the sir this movie 5
yeah I'm important technical point is
what happens after Bishop
takes 22 ok you can say well I recapture
but this is not really working after
Queen g7 what exactly as his whites
whites move he has an attack that's
clear but he doesn't have a decisive
blow instead after this capture on g2
white has a much stronger move and maybe
this is what the pile of had overlooked
it's possible white so has this
intermediate move he takes f6 and this
is much stronger it just ignores the
bishop on energy to white does not
really need to recapture that and yeah
how how to defend him splack it's it's
already am beyond saving one one idea
one additional idea here now is Queen g
6 + f7 I have for instance let's say I
move like that ok and black has no way
to save himself Queen age 6 meet you
need to play something like rook takes
f7 and this only delays made for three
moves this is the the new threat
introduced by the appearance of the porn
on f6 he played rock take g6 getting rid
of the night but white can serve you we
capture and keeps all the attacking
ideas intact Bishop b4 and you just took
only six this is another another idea
why does just having a decisive attack
93 well Lex last try threatening Queen
takes f to mate so always need to be
cautious till the end white can just
cover this the easiest move Queen age 7
and now check f7 was played and the T
reason already I didn't but ok this is a
this is a decisive move after Luke
Jake's chat as this mate shank Nate
so Queen takes will plate and now we
just just took the bishop with this
threat again in the position coming here
rookie seven and now to palo resigned
yeah this was I think Alan's arm
probably most convincing game from this
world championship match as mentioned he
also won the final game and the decisive
game but this was probably the most
aesthetic win and also I really like
this concept of 93 this is this is just
interesting to use the night on the edge
of the board we can see that this night
really soft a very clear purpose and
contrast to blacks nights irani here on
a six and before those pieces were
mostly spectators while white was
preparing the decisive attack on the
Kings side this is in fact i'm finna
phenomenon that is happening rather
often you have big pressure on one side
of the board and this somehow um tides
up the the defending pieces and then
when you have more more space on the
board like here white enjoys the space
advantage and the better mobilisation of
his forces then you can more quickly
shift your pieces over to the other side
and lend the decisive blow on the other
side this especially happens with the
king yeah white has this big cannot draw
arrows white has all this pressure on
the queenside on the center and this has
lured all pieces to the Queen side and
we see how quickly right now with the
Knights check gets to the decisive
attack against against the King so very
nice win we're honored
this also shows an important quality of
Alan's play he is able to to play a
really excellent chest under pressure in
these absolutely decisive situations in
the world championship matches what
Carlton really has no match experience
at all and he's played some I'm sorry
kind of two game many matches or four
game many matches some some years ago
but it's not compared to the 12-game
watch championship performant when
they're simply much much higher tension
so Islands experience under pressure
will certainly be an important born
factor and also we saw that here night a
three was a good novelty so hunter
always had a good team of seconds and we
will see how this is working out this
time because he am is not working in
this match with Peter Hyland yields in
his longtime second and also I think
chasm jonov is not in his team anymore
so it's a bit a bit different alright
thanks for watching I'll be back
tomorrow bye